let's talk about the diet for peripheral
neuropathy now what is peripheral neuropathy it
is a condition where you're experiencing tingling
numbness or burning type pain in the bottom
of your feet or your fingertips and the most
common way you would get peripheral neuropathy
is by having diabetes and so peripheral neuropathy
first starts in the longer nerves of the body okay
and it happens at the very end of that nerve and
what's happening is you're getting a destruction
of the tiny blood vessels to the nerves and
the destruction is not necessarily coming from
the high sugar directly or high blood glucose
directly the high blood glucose is creating
a lot of inflammation free radical damage and
destruction to the proteins on the inside of your
artery so it's going to clog this thing up it's
going to starve the blood supply to the nerve now
why is that blood supply there to feed the nerve
oxygen and nutrients and so peripheral neuropathy
is basically killing off the nerves so we're
getting microvascular damage also it's happening
in the eye too if you're a diabetic but what i
want to tell you especially if you're new to my
channel and you have peripheral neuropathy it is
actually very very easy to undo this condition and
get relief if you simply see this high sugar
right here start consuming low carbs that's
called a healthy ketogenic diet start doing low
carbs immediately i am blown away how many people
with peripheral neuropathy don't know this
information they're doing a high carb diet and
they're on the medication and they're suffering so
bad it's completely unnecessary this condition can
be reversed so you start doing low carbohydrate
especially if you're consuming high carbohydrates
with protein like most people do or high carb
with fat like an ice cream something like that
you're creating more damage than just carbs alone
when you combine a carb with a protein you create
something called glycation which basically
destroys certain proteins in the body that
now become permanent it's very difficult to undo
that and it clogs up all sorts of things as in
circulation you also want to make sure that you
have very low amounts of omega-6 oils in the diet
like for example the corn oil the soy oil that's
in the salad dressing it's in so many foods
especially if you go out to eat very often because
that's what they cook everything with it's also in
the soups it's in the breads and all that stuff
and then you also want to combine intermittent
fasting both of those together will put you in
really good shape and i put a link down below of
exactly how to do it but there's three additional
things that can help you get relief immediately
you can get these from the health of store
benfotiamine this is a fat soluble b1 i would take
four capsules a day spread them out what this
does is it helps to lower the inflammation and
the damage that's created from the high sugar
because the high sugar in your blood has created
a huge need for more b1 and so what the
body will do is starts to deplete your
b1 reserves until the point where you have no
more and then you can't actually make the myelin
sheath around the nerve which is the insulating
fat layer so you can't make that without b1
so you start putting it back in there and
things start to heal up alpha lipoic acid
is another very important one and even
this on its own has been known to improve
peripheral neuropathies so you can take
this as a supplement you can get it anywhere
and also tocatrinos this is a type of vitamin
e that works 50 times stronger than tocopherols
it's a powerful antioxidant all three of these
together plus the diet with intermittent fasting
would be a very powerful weapon against peripheral
neuropathy before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto and you want
to know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call but i put the number
down below so you can call and get some help